casi dos años y medio después de que se
detectara el covid 19 por primera vez el
director general de la Organización
Mundial de la Salud hizo un anuncio
importante
el comité de emergencia sobre el comité
19 se reunió el viernes de la semana
pasada y concluyó que el virus sigue
siendo una emergencia de salud pública
de interés internacional
los casos notificados a la OMS han
aumentado un 30% en los últimos 15 días
las pruebas para identificar el
coronavirus se han reducido
considerablemente y los diagnósticos
tratamientos y vacunas no se están
desplegando eficazmente herramientas que
han permitido desvincular los contagios
de las hospitalizaciones y muertes
las vacunas han salvado millones de
vidas y es importante que los gobiernos
se centren en reforzar las comunidades
de mayor riesgo encontrando a los no
vacunados para construir el muro de
inmunidad hacia el objetivo de
vacunación del 70%.
hasta el momento el 61,9% de la
población mundial ya ha sido inoculada
con el esquema completo a pesar de estar
cerca de la meta Pedro sadanongue
breyesus hizo un llamado a la comunidad
internacional
periódicamente sus planes de respuesta
el 19 basándose en la epidemiología
actual y también en la posibilidad de
que aparezcan nuevas variantes
se han producido más de 557 millones de
contagios y más de 6,3 millones de
decesos a causa del virus según un
estudio realizado por la organización
Our roading Data